[Musica]
lo staff di dx mi ha definito
international co leading experts quando
mi hanno chiamato per chiedermi se mi
andava bene come come appellativo ho
pensato caspita questo sì che è un modo
figo per descrivere quello che faccio
international living expert vuol dire
semplicemente che intenderò di
convincervi a prendervi un rifugiato in
casa e adesso vi spiego anche perché è
una fantastica idea nel 1991
avevo 8 anni andavano elementari e mia
mamma ogni mattina e preparava al latte
al cioccolato un ricordo di aver avuto
alcuna coscienza sociale all'epoca mio
padre mi costringeva a guardare il
telegiornale
scusate
[Applauso]
e non sapevo neanche dove fosse l'ex
jugoslavia una di quelle mattine quelle
del latte al cioccolato
mi sveglio arrivo in cucina assonnata
apro la porta è seduta a tavola c'era
una ragazza ma sconosciuta
me la ricordo come se fosse ieri
impacchettata in un pigiama azzurrino
con la testata ingestibile di caffè
direttrici è totalmente incapace di
pronunciare una singola parola nella mia
stessa lingua
io lei a tavola non ci conoscevamo e mia
mamma che preparava al latte durata all
epoca aveva 23 anni era albanese ed era
arrivata in italia con una nave la
ricordate la flora in un solo giorno all
8 agosto del 1991 appunto sbarcarono a
bari più di ventimila albanesi
ecco la mia famiglia di certo non era un
covo di buoni samaritani dediti all
altruismo e all'aiuto filantropico però
quelle immagini che passarono così tante
volte in televisione colpi erano così
tanto mia mamma mio papà che
praticamente qualche settimana settimana
dopo quello sbarco durata si ritrovò
seduta a tavola
accanto a me anche lei con il latte al
cioccolato mettersi in casa uno
straniero un profugo probabilmente non è
un'impresa comune
i miei genitori all'epoca sono stati
presi per pazzi però perché è in fondo
una delle recriminazioni più comuni che
sente usare a spron battuto da
giornalisti politici da una schiera
infinita di conoscenti parenti followers
su twitter e facebook di gente poi si
scatena prima gli italiani a cui seguono
quasi sempre corollari come ci invadono
cancelleranno le nostre tradizioni ecco
queste due affermazioni non so a voi ma
a me sembrano abbastanza obsolete
vecchie non so mi hanno portato a farmi
delle domande che cosa vuol dire essere
italiano quali sono le nostre le nostre
tradizioni la nostra italianità da dove
viene
ecco che cosa vuol dire essere italiano
per esempio da dove si parte a chiamare
qualcuno italia
piano da dove come possiamo definirci
italiani non so se partiamo dall unità
d'italia per esempio
vorrebbe dire che ci potremo
immediatamente scordare di vantarci del
colosseo per esempio figuriamoci
l'impero romano che faccia buio di idee
di culture di dio mi doveva essere di
certo non erano italiane così come
potremmo piantarla di vantarci degli
uffici del castello sforzesco del duomo
di monreale che tra franchi aragonesi
saraceni normanni
c'è di tutto di certo non si tratta di
italiane ecco io non ho ancora capito
che cosa voglia dire essere italiano per
quanto riguarda la tradizione ebbe
brancola nel buio sinceramente posso
pensare non solo al cibo perché per noi
è una cosa abbastanza rappresentativa e
siccome sono immigrata a milano e ripeto
è migrata perché io vengo da tutt'altra
parte d'italia
penso ormai risorsa farano risotto alla
milanese no e tipico ecco partiamo male
perché il riso e zafferano sono sono due
prodotti che non vengono dall'italia
sono arrivati dall'asia attraverso i
grandi cammini gli esploratori e
commercianti naviganti e lo zafferano la
tesi che credi tata per esempio dice
chiesti a sato monaco dell'inquisizione
spagnola portarlo in italia quindi non
si tratta di un prodotto tipico delle
valli padane
il punto è che il risotto alla milanese
non è l'idea di un milanese si il mito
vuole che sia rinato a milano però per
essere più specifici e nato alla tavola
di un banchetto di nozze di un vetraio
che per ora belga quindi il nocciolo la
questione per me è che le nostre
tradizioni sono per forza la commissione
del dell'incontro tra culture dei
diversi popoli perché se non mettiamo
questo per me non possiamo neanche più
sperare nel panettone immagino che i
milanesi sappiano che anche quello
probabilmente non è proprio un idea
meneghina va bene questo è
un'introduzione un po scema tra dirvi
che si può pensare che la nostra stessa
italianità non viene da noi stessi ma
viene dall'incontro di tantissime
culture
ora nel mondo esistono circa 60 milioni
di rifugiati persone che hanno dovuto
lasciare la propria casa per scappare da
guerre da calamità naturali e dalla
povertà
l'europa è solo una delle destinazioni
di queste persone
per essere precisi poi non è neanche la
destinazione più gettonata i flussi
migratori rifatti investono i paesi
limitrofi a quello di fuga per farvi un
esempio forse più banale in libano la
popolazione siriana supera la
popolazione di libanese residente
per quanto riguarda l'italia poi il
numero di richiedenti asilo in questo
momento è di circa 43.000 persone e ci
sono più o meno 5 milioni di stranieri
regolarmente residenti
non so voi ma a me non sembra che siamo
di fronte a un rischio di sconvolgimento
etnografico forse questo ci dovrebbe far
pensare le cose in una maniera
differente per esempio smettere di
pensare che siamo invasi e iniziare
ipotizzare che dalla dall'integrazione
dalla prosperità di queste persone delle
persone che arrivano qua possano nascere
benefici per la nostra stessa società
così come appunto è successo fino adesso
ecco che cosa succederebbe per esempio
se ognuno di noi potesse prendere in
considerazione di passare qualche tempo
con questi rifugiati che cosa
succederebbe se per sei mesi ci
svegliassimo ogni mattina e facessimo
colazione con questi rifugiati con
questi stranieri che ci invadono beh
forse succederebbe quello che è successo
la signora concetta siciliana doc che si
è messo in casa a 90 anni alfa 19 anni e
del male cosa è successo
si sono conosciuti hanno trovato il modo
di comunicare
in due lingue che sono totalmente
differenti l'una dall'altra hanno
trovato un modo di fidarsi l'uno
dell'altro
che poi stando alle parole della signora
concetta non si tratta di fare qualcosa
di eccezionale di fuori dal comune
si tratta di costruire e ricostruire una
quotidianità di andare a prendere il
pane di preparare un pranzo di
presentare su un amico di aiutarsi
perché per me per come vedo le cose non
si tratta di beneficenza sì lo slancio
può essere caritatevole umanitario
chiamatelo come volete però alla fine è
un aiuto tra pari una solidarietà è uno
scambio tra persone che stanno lo stesso
livello
così al fa quando torna a casa la sera
non ha solo una casa una casa non è solo
un tetto sopra la testa c'è concetta che
lo aspetta che poi in questo caso
l'abbia impazzata molto bene nel ragazzo
perché c'è la voce che la signora
concetta catania sia un'ottima cuoca e
quindi il ragazzo si è già preso 23 kg
ecco dall'altra parte c'è la signora
concetta che imparato cose nuove ha
imparato parole nuove e poi ogni giorno
si vede questo ragazzone alto e pieno di
vita che l'aiuta a stendere che la porta
fuori a fare due passi poi ci sei tu che
andato a vivere a casa della famiglia
spa da mamma papà 3 figli un cane un
pesce rosso quando sono andata a
trovarli a roma ho scoperto che la
cameretta di cecilia la più piccolina
era diventata la camera di 6 lug
e così in un guazzabuglio di peluche di
giocattoli di fotografie di poster
questo ragazzo del burkina faso ha
ritrovato una casa un luogo accogliente
un posto pieno d'amore che lo facesse
sentire di nuovo in famiglia un giorno
gli ho chiesto sei tu ma non hai mai
avuto paura di andare ad infilare in
casa di perfetti sconosciuti e lui
candidamente mi ha risposto che sì mi ha
risposto che gli italiani li facevano
una gran paura è che non sapeva come
l'avrebbero trattato ho fatto la stessa
domanda benedetto il papa gli ho chiesto
se non avesse avuto timore di mettersi
in casa un rifugiato
un africano contro i bimbetti piccoli in
casa per di più e lui mi ha guardato un
po imbarazzato e mi ha detto che sì che
abbia pensato che avrebbe avuto qualche
problema logistico che avrebbe
probabilmente dovuto evitare di girare
in casa in mutande poi però mi ha detto
anche che questa questa cosa era stata
risolta brillantemente ecco 62 adesso ho
trovato un lavoro part time e
sottopagato però comunque già un inizio
in primo passo verso l'integrazione e
continua studiare l'italiano a scuola ma
anche a casa perché a casa a quei tre
ragazzini che lo aspettano con compiti
esercizi ed esami a sorpresa ecco queste
sono due storie sono due storie che ti
fanno parte del grande mosaico che era
figisc welcome ha cercato di costruire
in questi due anni in due anni decine di
persone famiglie coppie e pensionati
hanno aperto la porta della propria casa
l'hanno fatto perché non volevano
restare con le mani in mano che la
storia non ci passa davanti un'altra
volta e noi stiamo girato dall'altra
parte l'hanno fatto perché volevano fare
del bene e perché come spesso ci hanno
detto forse era banale però se capitasse
a me vorrei che ci fosse qualcuno ad
aggiungere un posto a tavola anche per
me
durata la mia compagna di colazione
albanese adesso abita a qualche decina
di chilometri da ogni genitore con suo
marito ha recuperato un uliveto di olive
taggiasche taggiasche tipiche dalla mia
terra è un uliveto fatto a terrazzamenti
con le pietre a secco che i miei avi gli
italiani avevano costruito e chiara in
totale abbandono
mio papà accompagnato durata ad altare
quando si è sposata ecco tutto questo
bene è entrato in casa mia ed entrato
nella casa delle persone che hanno
deciso di accogliere perché se vogliamo
che le cose belle accadono
occorre aprire le porte altrimenti le
cose belle non riescono ad entrare
grazie